big breaking news author of the 10 week
in a row number one new york times
bestseller american marxism i call him
the great one he's the host of life
liberty levin right here on the fox news
channel
uh great one just a quick reaction to
that
i mean
you know the people that go to these
military academies we've met them
they're the most amazing people on earth
they're willing to risk their lives
sacrifice for their country work so hard
you would think there would be some type
of creative way to solve problems short
of
our way or the highway
what's happening throughout this country
listening to those wonderful patriots
there
is that the government is weeding out
people who just don't go along with
authoritarianism
um they're weeding out people through
these vaccine mandates many people who
have the
natural immunity they're going to be
fired
with an
legal mandate from joe biden
the federal government doesn't have
plenary police powers the states do
and osha has no statutory authority that
is the labor department over vaccines
if any department did and they don't it
would be hhs and notice they didn't
issue any regulation so this will be
defeated but it's the mentality it's the
totalitarian mentality and so they're
trying to weed out forces that support
freedom and reject authoritarianism
the war on the cops is a perfect example
the war on the military is another
example and it's going on throughout
this american marxism movement notice
this book american marxism that's not at
west point that's done in our schools
and why not
because this is the antidote to what's
going on in this country now the parents
in virginia and elsewhere who rose up
the parents in virginia and elsewhere
being a parent myself as our you
critical race theory is poison
but it's more than critical race theory
what's being done to your children
is outrageous what kind of a country are
we going to leave to our children and
grandchildren and generations yet born
this movement is across the board this
radical extremist movement i'll give you
some examples the debt
who's going to pay this debt we actually
have
moronic statements coming out of the
president the democrat party that
they're going to spend trillions in debt
but it doesn't create debt in fact it's
going to help eliminate the debt this is
how stupid they think we are that's not
true they want to expand medicare which
will destroy medicare well who's going
to pay for that your children and your
grandchildren this massive entitlement
education it's indoctrination it's
racism it's a radical left agenda
test scores are going down in every part
of this country what about immigration a
complete lack of assimilation
the borders wide open you're going to
have tribalization in the years ahead
what kind of country are we leaving our
children i would ask the parents of this
country look at the environment
under the environment we have this
primitive movement this regressive
movement that is a war on capitalism a
war on economic growth and opportunity a
war on private property rights this is
the core of americanism it's the core of
americanism they create impoverishment
they create lawlessness with their
agenda and so forth
let's go on national security what are
we doing about national security
china's on the rise china is building a
military that is prepared for war
our military is being gutted and
undermined with this social
agenda this critical race theory and a
thousand other ways it's not being
properly funded we're not building up
our military to confront china or russia
or iran or any of these other threats
that we face so one day our children and
grandchildren unfortunately because of
the provocative nature of these american
marxists and the democrat party are
going to have to defend this country
they're going to have to go to war for
this country
look at the constitution
we inherited a beautiful document the
greatest document on the face of the
earth for governance
it's under constant attack separation of
powers the independence of the judiciary
the imperial presidency war on the bill
of rights and so forth and so on
what kind of a country are we creating
and leaving to our children so the same
parents that rose up at school board
meetings the same parents are concerned
about critical race there and they sure
damn well should be the same parents are
concerned about
this transgender movement and the same
parents are concerned about who should
control what in their children's lives
you need to understand your children
grandchildren generations yet born are
being plundered they're being plundered
by joe biden by chuck schumer by nancy
pelosi and bernie sanders they're being
plundered by aoc
and to omar and talib they're being
plundered by this radicalism and this
extremism of these american marxist
movements and we need to understand we
need to be resolute a victory the other
day is a beautiful thing but this is one
battle after another after another it's
a battle over the culture it's a battle
over the economy it's a battle over
constitutional republicanism because
every one of these fundamental
principles that have given us
life liberty and prosperity is under
attack by the democrat party by their
surrogates in academia by the surrogates
in the media by their surrogates and
entertainment and so while the other
night was a grand victory it's one small
step
in what needs to be many many steps to
protect the future of our children so
parents and grandparents we need to step
up
fight in the classrooms fight the school
boards but fight this agenda also that's
coming out of washington and many of
these state capitals that are going to
destroy the future of your children and
devour their opportunity
that's it that's why we call them the
great one mark levine tune in life
liberty levin sunday nights eight
o'clock number one show right here fox
news hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else